I got in your truck cuz you guys seem
like some good guys you know plus if you
did try anything funny I'm pretty sure
even I could take photo fits right so
took this bites
mm-hmm
that's um thing
your brother has in there you need to
call someone about that can't do that
right
well
whatever it is you've gotten him into
he's gonna figure it out eventually I
hope you're ready for that
[Music]
my name is Joseph Fraley and on the
sound designer for the movie Kent it was
really early on that the directors
Jonathan and Josh Baker at the idea that
all the technology in the film have a
magnetic energy behind it so I spent a
lot of time generating and recording
sounds that would resemble magnetism
conceptually whether the sound was
organic or synthetic or a combination of
the two the goal was to create a world
of sound based around magnetism that was
hopefully unique to the audience
for the cleaners vocalizations that came
up with a process where I record long
passages of dialogue of both my wife and
I talking and then scramble and
processed the dialogue which enabled me
to go in later and edit together the
individual phonemes to create a new
language for these characters to
communicate with
[Music]
after spending a lot of time with the
film I had come to this idea that there
was artificial intelligence within the
technology that can differentiate
between who's using it and almost take
on their personality someone who
shouldn't be using it someone who should
be using it it'll behave and sound
differently based on what actions are
doing as well and that aspect of the
storytelling is all told through sound
he's mine
let him go
let him go and we'll leave
[Music]
like it worked oh oh he likes you just
fine huh let's see it again light up
that haystack right there come on man
don't be shy now you got this Oh
something please be careful it's my bag
my bag with all my money I left it in
the bar well how much are we talking
sixty seventy what thousand
yeah thousand sixty grand in a space gun
who the hell are you people get the
truck let's go
what is serious
if I'm hard on you it's because the
world is hard you've seen that and I
just need you stay out of trouble okay
[Music]
your brother just got out of prison I
know I've been away for a long time but
I want to make sure that you know that
you're important to me I want you to be
careful about him welcome home my man I
know I owe you guys some money I just
wanted you can all I'm not dodging you
let him go the hell is that thing
what the hell is that I found it
somebody's gotta be looking for this
thing
that thing your brother hasn't we need
to call someone ten tonight
[Music]
finally Jesus someone dangerous people
coming after us
I know I'm not a good guy but it's been
pretty incredible to be brothers for the
first time whatever he's gotten him into
he's gonna figure it out eventually I'll
be ready for that
I believe this whole time
you haven't told me there
[Music]
get away from my brother
maybe keep that thing on the first mode
yeah
[Music]
[Music]